Today will be showing you how to quickly
troubleshoot your production application
using Google Cloud Debugger. The debugger
helps you inspect the call stack
variables of your application without
stopping or slowing down. First make sure
the application is up and running.
Navigate to source code > debug in the
left nav, then the source code. Set a
snapshot by clicking in the gutter next
to the line we wish to investigate. Wait
for the request that triggers the snapshot.
That was fast! Look at the results
once triggered the snapshot returns
the call stack and
local variables without stopping or
slowing down your application. We've
shown you how to troubleshoot your
production application for additional
information take a look at the
documentation and we provide support on
Stackoverflow.